Now, I don't know about you, but I think this manual bug hunting is a little bit
tedious, so why don't we introduce you to some tools that will make our
lives a little bit easier. All the major browsers have developer tools
built into them that can help you with just the kind of problems that we are looking at,
and then some. Now if you're watching this in Google Chrome, you can open
the developer tools by moving over here, into Tools and
clicking on Developer Tools. Now you can see that there's a handy little shortcut here. Depending on
what platform you're on, that shortcut might be different. On Mac, it's Command
Option I. And you can see that it opens up this console here and if we were to
load our file with bugs into it, then you can see
that it starts catching syntax errors. Now, it only goes so far, and then it just crashes,
but you can see that it points us to the first syntax error here and then we can fix them as
necessary. If we kept going with this by fixing this, let's say and then
reloaded the page, you would see that it would get to the next error,
which is right in this for loop. Now, you notice that it skipped right over this error here:
didn't even catch it because the way Javascript handles semicolons.